So I, I'm a huge admirer of yours in large part because your origin story.
So I just wanted to geek out a little bit, um,
cause you and I have a lot in common,
I don't know if you know how much we have in common. So check it out.
I'm the child of Taiwanese American immigrants. Um,
my dad had a PhD in physics. Um, my mom had a master's in math.
They came here,
there was this period in the sixties when the U S was letting in Taiwanese grad
students. And so they came here and they,
they met each other and then they had me and my brother, um, in the seventies,
uh, I think you and I might even have been born the same year. Uh,
and then I went to Phillips Exeter, uh,
and graduated in 92. Uh,
and then I wound up going to Columbia for law school where you went to
undergrad. Um, so the, the thing that blows my mind about you, Jen,
is that you and I, I think, you know, how those things in common,
I think you pretty much everything. I just stated, um,
like it could have been you talking, but then,
but then you did something that was so unusual, certainly for our community.
It really, for anyone. Cause you know, there aren't,
there aren't many people like you. Um,
so you have this education that primes you for
doing frankly, you know,
like what a lot of our peers did out of a place like Columbia,
which would be a medicine, finance consulting,
business tech in my case law, um, and the rest of it.
But then you took a very,
very sharp detour and became a labor organizer.
So I would love to hear how the heck that happened.
Well, I had no idea. We had that many experiences in common.
That's incredible. Um, thank you for naming all of that.
We have lots to talk about. Um,
but in terms of how I became a labor organizer when I was in college at
Columbia, I,
one of the reasons why I wanted to go to Columbia was it was in New York city
and the city and its energy and its diversity and
communities and the size of the Asian immigrant community and New York were
some of the reasons why I wanted to be there.
And I started volunteering at a domestic violence shelter for Asian immigrant
women, and I could still speak Mandarin.
So it was actually a value in terms of being a bilingual hotline volunteer.
Um, and, um,
and a lot of the calls were not just about the struggles
of surviving violence or abuse,
but a lot of them were about how hard it was to just survive
as a mom. Um, as someone working in a low wage service job,
you know,
I would hear from women who were domestic violence survivors who were working
in, um,
nail salons are doing domestic work and long,
long hours and still not able to pay the rent, um,
or, you know, cover the expenses related to school for kids.
And I just remember thinking like how could it be that there's so many people
who work so hard and do everything right and survive
so much and still can't make a decent living and take care of the
people they love.
And that kind of led me down a path of trying to figure out how we make work
better for women, especially women in our communities, women of color,
um,
women who are really struggling at the bottom of the economy where we just don't
value so much work. That's actually essential.
There are a lot of people who fall frankly,
volunteer at non-profits when they're in college. Um,
but then they don't make a career out of it in the same way that you have.
So like the, the thing that, uh, again, I was wanting,
because I'm genuinely curious, I think you can tell is, um,
so you're an undergrad you're volunteering downtown. Um,
and then like how are you spending your summers? Like,
and what is your first job, um, when you graduated from school,
uh, and also like, how is your family taking this in,
but I'd love to start really like with, um,
what your college career looked like and then what, what your first job was.
Yeah. So in college I volunteered at the New York Asian women's shelter.
And then also at the committee against anti-Asian violence, as you mentioned,
where we started the women workers project that led to, um,
lots of the other work to organize domestic workers. Um,
and then I also on campus was involved in, um,
a campaign in 1996 to win ethnic studies, um,
on campus at Columbia. So, um, in the spring of 1996,
there was kind of a multiracial coalition of students who came together to fight
for an ethnic studies department and the combination of the
volunteering on campus or the volunteering outside of campus in the community
and the work to try to change how things worked on campus
and working across race. It was really transformative to me. Like I,
the fact that we actually waged a campaign, we took over buildings,
we went on a hunger strike, we did all kinds of stuff. And we won,
there's now a center for the study of ethnicity and race at Columbia
because of the activism that we did.
And I think I got kind of addicted to winning.
I just got really excited about the fact that you actually.
Want for one, what else can I do?
Yeah, I kind of was like, Hey, you could get just like regular people together,
get together and fight for something and make some real change that can
affect future generations. And I think I kind of caught the bug,
but I didn't know that you could make it a career to be honest, Andrew.
Yeah, no, there was no, I did not think of it as a career.
I thought maybe I would be a writer. Um, uh,
I was tutoring at the borough of Manhattan community college, um,
as a, you know, in the summers.
And then after I graduated to help people prepare for the writing assessment
test, um,
I thought I would like get some kind of a job to pay the bills while I wrote,
um, I R or something like that. Yeah, exactly.
I also worked in restaurants.
I was waited tables and I worked as a bartender.
Like how did you figure out that activism was that actual career choice
after you'd had this massive victory, your senior spring?
I didn't really know that it was, um, we, uh, at,
when I was working,
when I was volunteering at Cav and we started the women workers project,
the committee against anti-Asian violence,
we started the women workers project as kind of an all volunteer committee,
um, to do outreach to women,
working in different low wage service jobs and to try to organize for better
conditions. And, um, we were all volunteer and then,
um, we realized that we needed somebody full-time,
who would get up every day and really be thinking about how to move this work
forward and follow through and keep in touch with the workers we were meeting.
And, um, and we put together a job description.
We applied for some grant money to fund the position.
And I really didn't think that I would do that,
but when nobody applied for the job,
everyone in the volunteer committee convinced me to do it. Um,
so I started out doing it part time for awhile, and then it became full-time.
And I think what I'll say is that even then, um,
I didn't think of it as my life's path. I just kind of,
I think I followed the women that I met and
organized with along the way and was so moved by the
incredible courage and resilience of the women that I would meet in the work.
And I just kind of took their lead and kept going and,
um, and we would win along the way.
And that also kept me going.
Wow. So you're kind of, you're tutoring, you're, uh,
um, bartending and then you're volunteering.
And then the volunteerism gets to a point, I was like, Hey,
someone should actually start doing this. Uh, like part-time.
So do you remember who the original grand tours were to fund the,
this part-time and then full-time position?
I think the New York women's foundation and the Ms
foundation, maybe, um, the North stars.
Yeah. Some,
some of the grassroots social justice foundations in New York city
really important early supporters for seed projects like that.
So listen to this philanthropists and funders, you end up funding these,
uh, these positions, and then sometimes they end up, uh,
mushroom going into these world, changing activists doesn't happen, you know,
if you don't fund it, who knows, maybe I is, uh, is, uh,
doing something else right now. No, you never know. So well,
they had the pistes you gotta get in there early. Uh, so you're working,
um, uh, uh, eventually a full-time role, um,
for Cav. And then you wound up transitioning into, uh,
starting your own, um,
or organizing really domestic workers and starting an organization to that
effect. Um, what does that arc like? Because I, you know,
I can see the volunteer, I can see, okay, no one else wants to do it.
So everyone's like, hi Jen, you do it. And,
and one of the things that happens in these environments,
it's a little bit like a school project where responsibility ends up falling on
whoever the most competent person is. You know what I mean? Like, like if,
if you have like a class project and there are five of you and then there's one
person who's on top of it and the other four, you know, not as good,
so that everyone's like, Ooh, person, who's on top of it. Let's like, so I can,
I can imagine that happening. And I can imagine, um, you know,
you're doing it full time,
but then there was like this entire arc where you go from part-time to full-time
to actually starting your own organization, which is a very, very big deal. Um,
and this, I I'd imagine happened this arc transpired,
it seems like throughout your twenties. Hmm.
Well,
one thing that your listeners should really know is that none of these things
are because of singular individuals, um, or processes.
And at least in my experience,
I've been organizing for twenty-five years and it has always
been a collective effort.
And maybe my name is on paper as the staff person or as the executive
director or as a co-founder, but it takes, um,
groups of us squats. It's always a squad effort I find.
Um, and I'm sure you found this too with your campaign. Andrew's like, it took,
like,
there was just like an essential core group every time to really take the work
to the next level. And, um, and that's really,
I think the story of the domestic workers movement that I've been a part of has
been, it was like a group of Filipino,
domestic workers who decided to take the project multi-racial and then a
group of Caribbean women who decide to really expand,
strengthen the work in New York city together with Filipinas
and South Asian women and Latina workers.
And then a group of New York workers then get together with a group of
workers from LA DC, Seattle, San Francisco.
And then we launched the national Alliance.
We had 50 co-founders of the national Alliance in 2007,
and then a group of us, you know, in the domestic workers movement.
After the 2016 elections, you know, bunch of domestic workers said,
we need an advocacy platform.
We have to be able to use every tool at our disposal to make this
democracy, to save our democracy and to make it work for us.
And so that's how Karen action was formed. And it was never ever me.
I I'm often the fundraiser.
To be honest.
But, um,
there's so much leadership and so much collective leadership behind
every effort and every breakthrough. And,
and so many of the people who made this moment in the movement
possible, their names that you'll never hear of,
but who were absolutely essential to the work.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notification so we can let you know every time we have a new
episode.